lie to the american people
and repeatedly lie about the state of
this pandemic
we saw him refuse to take responsibility
for the crisis that
should have been met with real
presidential leadership
instead it has cost hundreds of
thousands of americans lives
and pushed millions into poverty we saw
him diminish
the pain felt by so many americans
president trump said we're rounding the
corner
it's going away we're learning to live
with it there are quotes
but as i told them last night we're not
learning to live with it
we're learning to die with it this is a
dark winter ahead
already more than 220 000 people in the
united states of america
have lost their lives with this virus
000 empty chairs and dinner tables all
across this country
my heart goes out to every single person
who's had to endure the agony
of saying goodbye to someone they loved
and adored
over a video chat who couldn't gather
their closest friends even their full
family
to grieve together at a funeral mass or
funeral service
and worse yet a new study from columbia
university suggested
anywhere between 130 000
and 210 000 of those deaths
were avoidable a leading medical journal
in america quite frankly in the world
wrote an unprecedented editorial
to the best of my knowledge they've
never written anything like this they
criticized president trump's quote
dangerously incompetent
end-of-quote response and stated that he
quote
took a crisis and turned it into a
tragedy
cover 19 dwarfs anything we've faced in
recent history
and it isn't showing any signs of
slowing down
the virus is surging in almost every
state
we passed 4.8 million cases
and when trump was asked this week what
did he do differently to get the
pandemic response right from the start
his answer was and i quote not much
not much
as many as 210 000 avoidable deaths
but there's not much he would do
differently
the united states is four percent of the
entire
world's population yet we make up
20 of all the deaths
worldwide if this is
a success what's a failure look like
we're more than eight months into this
crisis
and the president still doesn't have a
plan
he's given up he's quit on you he's quit
on your family
he's quit on america he just wants us to
grow
numb and resign to the horrors of this
death toll
and the pain is causing so many
americans
but he can't erase his own words or
deeds
in february he knew just how dangerous
this virus was
he told bob woodruin in a taped
interview this disease was
deadly far worse than the flu
but instead of telling us how bad it was
going to be
according to the new york times
his administration only gave wall street
investors a head up
heads up and they made a bundle
doing something calling calls selling
short
or betting against the market
so wall street newell was coming while
the rest of us took the full brunt of it
in june when we began to see the
resurgence of covet 19
i called out president trump for
wavering
and waving the white flag of surrender
to the virus
but then it was as if he decided to
go on offense for the virus
holding rallies with no masks no social
distancing
where people contracted the virus
inviting the virus into the white house
hosting what dr fauci called super
spreader event
endangering more people's lives by
telling the public don't worry
don't worry about the disease don't let
it dominate you
how many people from christian in
arizona
will end up suffering because their
loved one listened to the president
kristen said her dad voted for trump
listened to him
believed him that the virus wasn't a big
deal
then her dad became infected and died
kristen said it was her dad's only
pre-existing condition
this is her quote the only pre-existing
condition was trusting donald trump
and the quote even after contracting the
virus himself donald trump still
still refuses to promote universal
masquerading
which could have saved nearly 100 000
lives
and could still save over 100 000 lives
in the next few months
the longer donald trump is present the
more reckless he gets
we don't have to be held prisoner by
this administration's failures
we can choose a different path we can do
what americans have
always done come together and meet the
challenge with grit
compassion and determination and today
i'm going to tell you exactly
what i plan to do if i have the honor of
being elected your next president
i'll immediately put in place a national
strategy
they'll position our country to finally
get ahead of this virus
and get back our lives i'll reach out to
every governor in every state
red and blue as well as mayors and local
officials
during transition to find out what
support they need
and how much of it they need
i'll ask the new congress to put a bill
on my desk by the end of january
with all the resources necessary to see
how both our public health
and our economic response can be seen
through the end
what is needed look a pandemic doesn't
play favors
nor will i as i said no red states no
blue states
just the united states united in our
response
united in our purpose to stop the spread
of covet 19 and
beat this virus
first i'll go to every governor urge
them to mandate mass wearing in their
states
and if they refuse i'll go to the mayors
and county executives and get local
masking requirements in place
nationwide as president i'll mandate
masquerade in all federal buildings and
all
interstate transportation because mass
saved lives period
just look what happened in arizona
republican governor initially tried to
bar
local governments from implementing
mandates on their communities
what happened in june arizona got hit
with a surge of cases
hospitals were flooded the state health
system was overwhelmed
so cities and counties appealed the
governor's ruling
they imposed their own local mandates
covering most of the state the result
cases fell by 75 percent
wearing a mask is not a political
statement it's a scientific
imperative it's a point of patriotic
pride
so we can pull our country out of this
god-awful spiral we're in
and it's a testament to the values we
were taught by our families and by our
faiths
love thy neighbor as thyself
second i'll put a national testing plan
in place
with a goal of testing as many people
each day
as we're currently testing each week a
seven
fold increase there's a key difference
in this campaign between donald trump
and me
i believe in testing donald trump does
not
i believe in science i believe in public
health officials
i believe in the example of other
countries which prove that widespread
testing is needed to regain
the health of our nation to reopen
safely
and critically to stay open
every school every worker every american
should have easy access to regular
reliable
free testing to achieve this
we need to increase both lab-based
diagnostic testing
with the results back within 24 hours or
less
and faster cheaper screening tests that
you could take right at home or in
school
look what we have right now isn't
anywhere near good enough
states are still improvising on the fly
school districts are still mostly on
their own
and many americans still don't know when
it's important to get a test or how
this isn't beyond our capacity to master
not if we're directing a coordinated
effort across government
and the private sector instead of
leaving
chaos terrain we'll manufacture the lab
supplies needed to make sure
we have enough tests and we'll tap
more of our nation's lab capacity so you
can get your test results
more quickly we'll build a national core
of contact tracers
to work closely with trusted
organizations in these communities
that are most at risk
we'll also take steps to ensure that no
one has to choose be
between getting a test and putting food
on the table
look and that no one
no one is scared that being tested for
covet
might jeopardize their immigration
status
the only way we'll defeat this virus is
if we defeat it everywhere
the third point i'd like to make is
we'll close the personal protective
equipment the ppe
gap and get the gear outwards needed
every healthcare worker will have a
reliable supply
of properly fitted n95 mask
it's unconscionable there are more than
eight months into this crisis and
frontline healthcare workers are still
rationing their personal protective
equipment
as president i'll use the full power of
the defense production act
to drive the manufacturing of personal
protective equipment
masks gloves gowns and more
and ensure this distributed equitably
look we won't stop until the nation's
supply exceeds the demand
and our stockpile is replenished
especially in hearted areas
and in communities that are
disproportionately impacted by the virus
i will appoint a fully empowered i will
appoint a fully empowered
supply commander who's in charge of
filling in the gaps
we'll make sure we can manufacture
critical supplies right here at home
so we're not dependent on other
countries in this crisis
fourth will provide consistent reliable
trusted detailed nationwide guidance and
technical support
for reopening safely and the resources
to make it happen
we need a single source of guidance that
we can trust
where we know the information won't
change
by for any reason other than the science
that guides it
not political expediency not public
image
it won't be easy as to open or close
social distances
isn't an on or off thing and we're
learning more every day about the virus
and how it spreads we need to be able to
adapt and adjust
our behavior to responsibly respond
appropriately
but schools and businesses can't be
responsible make responsible decisions
if they don't have the information the
science
not just more detail effective guidance
they need
it's consultations and technical support
so people have a place to turn
with their questions
it's having a government that's in your
corner not a government that's
turned his back on you once we get our
federal state and local governments
working together
once there's universal masking enough
ppe and testing to go around
science back guidance to help us make
the right decision
then we can get our kids back to school
safely our business is growing
and our economy running again without
wasting another minute
as i said last night i'm not going to
shut down
the economy i'm not going to shut down
the country
i'm going to shut down the virus
and finally we focus on developing safe
and effective treatments
and distributing a safe and effective
vaccine
president trump claims he found a cure
well let me tell you yet we have 1 000
people dying each day
more than 40 000 people are in hospitals
right now battling the virus
life-saving therapies shouldn't be just
available to the wealthy they're all
connected
we need to make sure they're available
to everybody available and affordable
it's also possible we could learn any
day that one of these vaccines
currently in trial is showing itself to
be effective
that will be a wonderful day for our
people and people around the world
everywhere
whether it comes next week or the next
two months
but it's still it will still be
many months before any vaccine is widely
available
and we need a president who will take
responsibility for making sure it gets
to
every single person in this country in a
way that's equitable
and accountable we need a president
who in the meantime is doing his job to
protect the american people
once we have a safe and effective
vaccine it has to be
free to everyone whether or not you're
insured
let me say that again the vaccine must
be free
and freely available to everyone
this is just not one more reason why
it's so
despicable that donald trump is fighting
in the middle of a pandemic to get the
u.s supreme court to strike down the
entire affordable care act which i work
so damn hard to get the votes for
under the aca insurers are required to
cover
recommended vaccines for free
so overturning the aca would mean people
have to pay to get cover 19 vaccine
that's wrong very very wrong
unlike donald trump i believe health
care isn't a privilege i think it's a
right
that's why as president i'll protect and
build on the aca by adding a public
option
that will compete with private plans to
expand coverage and lower health care
costs across the board
i'll bring down drug prices by allowing
medicare
to negotiate with pharmaceutical
companies
i'll make sure americans have insurance
those with insurance have access
to free covert 19 vaccine
i'll direct the federal government to
bulk purchase
as many doses as necessary of the cova
19 vaccine so we can provide it free
to those who are uninsured underinsured
or medicaid eligible
throughout all this throughout all this
yes mr president i'll listen to the
scientists
and i'll empower them
i know how much president trump has
damaged
faith in our institutions and our
leaders
in government itself we have to rebuild
the trust
between the public and his public
servants it's one of the most difficult
tasks we'll face in the coming years
but if i'm elected president i'll always
give it to you as fdr said
straight from the shoulder i'll deliver
on my promises
i'll listen to the american people no
matter what their politics
i'll let the doctors and the scientists
speak freely so you can make the best
decision possible for yourself
and for your family and i won't let
four years of donald trump rob us of the
most fundamental american qualities
our hope in the future and our faith in
ourselves
we can beat this virus we're not too
divided to achieve big things
we're america we can do this we've never
failed
when we work together imagine imagine a
true
nationally coordinated plan where we
spare no expense
so our schools have the resources they
need to reopen with full health and
safety protocols in place
imagine every small business getting a
restart package
that helps cover the cost of installing
plexiglass providing ppe
and more to minimize the risk of
exposure for customers and workers
imagine their older americans and people
with disabilities having the peace of
mind that comes
with trusting that the public health
system is working
for them imagine
instead of staying locked up in their
rooms they're able to hug their
grandchildren
or other those who they love haven't
been able to see
imagine if you're a member of a
community that has been hit particularly
hard
black latino asian americans or native
americans
imagine a public health and economic
response that treats your needs as a
priority
not as an afterthought
imagine a day in the not too distant
future
when you can enjoy dinner with your
friends and your family
maybe even go out to a movie
when you can celebrate your birthday
weddings graduations surrounded by your
nearest and dearest friends
that's the biden harris agenda to beat
cover 19.
it's going to take all of us working
together and that's not hyperbole
all of us working together watching out
for one another
we're all still going to have to wear
our mask
a practical social distancing a while
longer
it's going to be hard but if we follow
the signs
and keep faith with one another with one
another
i promise you we'll get through this and
come out the other side
much faster than the rate we're going
now
look you all know this the american
people have always given their best to
this country in times of crisis
and this time isn't any different
i'm not joking when i say this i think
every day about the brave doctors and
nurses and hospital workers
police officers firefighters emts and
other first responders
who not figuratively but literally are
putting their lives on the line
day in and day out to care for people
i think the essential workers who
carried the rest of us on their
shoulders through these many months
the grocery store clerks the delivery
clerks the drivers
the folks on the assembly line the meat
packers so many more
people too often overlooked too
often overlooked undercompensated
they've given the best to their country
when we need them the most
think of the small businesses who moved
heaven and earth
to try to take care of their employees
and keep their businesses open
and sadly of all those who couldn't
because they didn't get the help they
were promised
i think of the parents juggling working
from home with the added demands of
overseeing the child's educations
i think about the educators who are
spending hours learning how to teach
online
they're doing what they always do giving
above and beyond
for their students i think of the
families in the communities
who have stepped up donating to
charities
doing grocery runs for older relatives
and neighbors
finding new ways to connect and support
one another
that's the america we know that's the
united states of america that's who we
are
and like john kent john f kennedy
when he committed to take us to the moon
he said i refuse to postpone
the possibilities that exist for this
country i refuse to postpone
refuse to postpone the american purpose
that will not only
lead our country back but lead the
entire world
there's no challenge there's no
challenge we cannot meet
no enemy we're unable to face
no threat we can't conquer
we stand together united
bound by our common resolve
determination and values
folks together we can harness the
unlimited potential of the american
people
not just to get back where we're before
this virus hit us
but to get back better i promise you
and you know in your heart we can do
this
we must do this and we will do it
together
you know we can do it this is the united
states of america
may god bless you all and may god
protect our frontline workers
and all those who have lost a loved one
thank you and keep the faith
uh
you